simplifica la expresión racional y
enuncia el dominio muy bien aquí tenemos
un trinomio dividido entre otro trinomio
de modo que para simplificar tenemos que
factorizar el numerador y el denominador
y factorizar también nos va a ayudar a
encontrar el dominio es decir a
encontrar aquellos valores de x para los
cuales esta expresión no queda
indefinida bueno déjame empezar factor
izando el numerador lo voy a reescribir
déjame marcarlo así en color rojo para
indicar qué es lo que estoy poniendo
aquí abajo entonces lo voy a poner aquí
es 2 x al cuadrado más 13 x más 20 y
queremos factorizar lo como aquí el
término principal no es uno sino es dos
lo que más nos conviene es factorizar lo
por agrupamiento y para factorizar esta
expresión por agrupamiento debemos
encontrar dos números a ive de modo que
el producto a por b sea igual a 2 por 20
o sea 40
y que la suma a más bien
jamás sea igual al término del medio o
más bien al coeficiente del medio o sea
13 13 y aquí los números brincan
inmediatamente verdad son 5 y 8 5 x 8 es
igual a 45 más 8 es igual a 13 bueno
entonces déjame reescribir esta
expresión utilizando la técnica de
agrupamiento el 2x al cuadrado queda
igual 2 x al cuadrado y ahora vamos a
dividir este 13 lo vamos a separar en 5
x más 8 x justo este es el chiste de la
técnica de agrupamiento verdad entonces
este 13 x lo voy a poner así primero voy
a poner el 8x y luego voy a sumar 5x y
después voy a sumar este 20 que falta
entonces sería más 20 y puse primero el
8 porque 8 comparte factor con 2 y luego
el 5 porque 5 comparte factor con 20
entonces pues al parecer esto debería
funcionar bueno el siguiente paso es
ahora factorizar aquí cosas que tengan
en común y acá también cosas que tengan
en común y me parece que lo mejor que
podemos factory
en estos primeros dos suman 2 es 2 x
tanto el primer sumando como el segundo
son múltiplos de 2x entonces quedaría 2x
x 2 x cuadrada entre 2 x x
+ 8x / 2 x que es 4 x 4 muy bien ahora
vamos a pasar al segundo término este de
acá 5x + 20 estos dos lo que tienen en
común es el 5 entonces factor hizo el 5
y me queda aquí x + 4 y notemos que
ahora tanto este sumando como éste
tienen al x más cuatro en común así que
ahora voy a factorizar este x más 4 de
aquí y de acá lo voy a poner así x + 4 y
tendría que multiplicarlo por 2 x 2 x +
+ 5 muy bien entonces con esto ya queda
factor izado nuestro numerador va ahora
vamos a pasar al denominador déjame
tomar otro color digamos color rosa y
este color rosa está bien entonces voy a
tomar este color rosa para tomar el
denominador y lo voy a pasar acá voy a
hacerle exactamente lo mismo sería 2x al
cuadrado más 17 x más 30 muy bien
entonces vamos a factorizar lo
utilizando agrupamiento una vez más
ahora necesitamos dos números a ive que
multiplicados sean igualados por 30 o
sea 60
y que sumados nos den el coeficiente del
medio o sea 17 y estos no están tan
fáciles pero pero igual tampoco están
tan complicados son 5 y 12 5 12 17 5 x
12 es igual a 60 entonces este 17 lo
debo separar en 12 x + 5x y el 12
conviene que quede con el 2 y el 5 con
el 30 para que los factores pues
correspondan entonces voy a poner 2 x al
cuadrado 2 x al cuadrado más el 17 x lo
voy a partir como como que dije 5 y 2
entonces como 12 x + 5 x más 30 este 30
de acá 30 misma idea ahora vamos con
estos dos que tienen de factor en común
pues ahora tienen un 2 x verdad sería 2
x x 2 x cuadrado / 2 x es x + 12 x / 2x
que es 6 ya eso le tengo que sumar y
ahora vamos a factorizar estos de acá lo
voy a marcar en color rosa y lo que
comparten es el 5 entonces sería 5 x x +
+ 6 y ahora aparece el x 6 en ambos
términos
lo voy a indicar en color naranja y lo
voy a factorizar me quedaría x + 6 x 2 x
+ 5 2 x + 5 y con esto ya tengo factor
izados el numerador y el denominador
déjame escribirlos aquí arriba entonces
esa expresión es igual a como el color
rojo x + 4 x 2 x 5
x 2 x 5 2 x 5 y eso lo tenemos que
dividir entre x 4 voy a tomar este color
1 x 6 verdad x 6
x 2 x 5 2 x + 5 muy bien y aquí podemos
ver que el 2 x 5 del numerador y del
denominador se simplifican pero antes de
eso vamos a hacer las cosas con cuidado
y pasemos primero a la segunda parte de
la pregunta vamos a enunciar el dominio
queremos encontrar aquellos valores para
los cuales esta expresión queda bien
definida es decir lo que queremos evitar
es prácticamente que hagamos una
división entre 0 y que pasaría o que
valores de x nos darían una división
entre 0 bueno si tuviéramos que x más 60
lo voy a poner por acá si x más 60
entonces ahí se define la expresión o
sea cuando x es igual a menos 6 o bien
cuando 2 x + 5 es igual a 0 2 x 5 es
igual a 0
restando 5 de ambos lados 2x es igual a
menos 5 y dividiendo entre 2 x es igual
a menos 5 medios entonces debemos evitar
los valores menos 6 y menos cinco medios
lo voy a poner aquí abajo el dominio
dominio
el dominio para x son todos los números
reales todos los números los números
números reales reales excepto excepto
excepto menos seis y menos cinco menos
seis y menos cinco medios y debemos
evitar estos dos números porque si x es
menos seis o menos cinco medios entonces
el denominador se hace cero y esto
quedaría indefinido bueno ya que tenemos
el dominio ahora sí podemos simplificar
como 2 x + 5 nunca es cero ya que x
nunca es menos 5 medios este término se
puede cancelar con este término y de
esta forma la expresión racional
simplificada es x + 4 x 4 / x +